hello everybody my name is Mark BL and
welcome to the complex otherwise known
as oh back rooms well it's actually not
connected to any established back rooms
lore but it is backs es all right let's
do this
yes you know for all my talk about the
back rooms I don't really uh have much
experience with playing these games I've
played a few here and there but I know
there have been many that are like
actually multiplayer and exploration
based this one is
solo D my
birthday 212 mic check is this
Newman oh this is
David this is being documented by Newman
Joseph Miller on June 24th
H damn you know they gotten really good
at the um
at the uh fussing up the image enough to
make it look real good God this sure
does yeah that's really
impressive it just takes muddying up the
image enough have any idea what's beyond
the gap or am I just going in blind no I
don't think
so they haven't gone through yet so I
think you're the first
one uh-huh well who laid down the tape
then
also dead
ass so uh yeah who put these
here contact Expedition supervisor for
more information well you didn't you
just say that I'm the first one down
here why you lie to me also what happens
if I go off the
trail
nothing although I should probably
probably be careful because there could
be something
wrong also don't go too far past the
cross stage there I don't want you to
get lost
accidentally uhhuh yeah I don't think
I'll get lost to be honest
still you have to wait for further
instructions to move so just describe
his surroundings whenever you see
something new or
different
uhhuh okay I'm going off the beat
path all
right seems like despite my best efforts
I'm not killed or horribly lost forever
in all
eternity is there someone who are
you who are you okay we're
in oh this is the gap you're talking
about do I not have a choice I guess
this is my job all right you
ready
yeah I don't think I was ready oh boy um
can I go back hey I'm
[Music]
uh yeah copy
that all right so I'm I'm getting paid
extra for this right
this isn't an SCP thing where I'm just a
prisoner and being thrown into this you
know it's it's really um volunteer
effort all
right okay I made it can I stand up
now it's just a
room there a hallway leing
out
uh-huh all
right it's an unusual hallway it's
wallpapered on all
sides there's also like a indoor house
light
guys well
[Music]
that's what you get that's what you get
um there really is no benefit in
exploring these places but I do know
they're probably hi oh the camera fell
that's
right
uhhuh okay so I no clip deeper into the
back rooms
but where I go from here I do not
know something tells me I probably
shouldn't
run what's going on over there
probably shouldn't
what is
that is that is that a
mall is that a business this is a house
Red Cross Red Cross
clothing am I a
mall
huh all
right there a door here I don't know who
I'm reporting this to if you're finding
this and you're watching this poly
because I'm still lost and also dead I
can
zoom I don't know how to unzoom there we
go okay well that's
fun thought I saw
something
weird
Okay so the this begins my Adventures of
being uh perpetually tormented in the
complex not the back rooms the
complex well at least they have fire
safety I wonder what would happen if you
busted open one of these drop ceilings
you know cuz that's what these are
they're drop ceilings not that they have
to still be that but for the most part I
assume that a lot of this is still like
drywall it's just that the drywall goes
on on forever I mean I'm sure there's
documentation about this and whatever
the back rooms Wiki
is but uh
o well that's something
different why not why not go into the
basement I can't run downstairs it's
just not
safe
uh-huh The Pink
Door not nothing really nothing you're
going to put a pink door down here
aesthetically it's beautiful the pink on
yellow very Warf stash but at the same
time why was that down there I guess I
could say the same thing about anything
in the back rooms all of it seems like a
bunch of nonsense a bunch of nonsense
that I'm going to die
in help help
me
help help
help
whoa I heard
something oh
hi what am I looking at is this another
door that I can't open oh my
God oh my
God
okay huh
oh the first bit of furniture I've
seen that's
weird okie dokie then not sure why
that's there not sure if I'm supposed to
make anything what
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what just
happened also what's that
sound I haven't noticed many Sounds here
I don't think the world just changed I
think that was just my mouse being
funny
okay there's some weird ulating
occurring through the wall to my right I
don't know why but it's
there
oh I don't want anyone to comment on the
type of sound that I just made I don't
want anyone to hear about it I don't
want anyone to talk about it I don't
want anyone to acknowledge that it even
happened we don't need to hi I remember
you something about you're from this
weird music video or
something oh that's
horrifying God that looks weirdly
real do I have a
flashlight I just
okay okay that's fine it is bizarre how
realistic this does look cuz it does
okay like if you squinted your eyes
which is what all the filters are doing
anyway they're trying to squint your
eyes for you so it's kind of obscured it
looks weirdly real it looks weirdly
real this is
partly due to the camera movements but
also the photo
textures all right
nothing why did I come
here I mean this is kind of like cheat
codes for game design where it's like oh
yeah the level design doesn't have to
make sense you can make things go
wherever you want and like that's true
in the back rooms and it's like
everything is supposed to be that way
and then people will be like Yay I'm
lost yippe you're telling me that I went
all the way back there and that was
nothing all right well that was fun glad
I did
that kind of hard to run in these big
bulky yellow
suits isn't this just back the way I
came yeah it is back the way I came it's
weird I feel like that should have been
the way forward even if it is just like
a it's back rooms nothing makes sense
here you
E look out for the
sinks you know but I felt like there was
something going on
there
Gap
peekabo
peekaboo all right
fine how is it not this way that's what
I want to know how is it
not what are
you whoa what the freak I had a light
this whole
time what do you mean I have a
light space why is space
that oh I can oh it's F oh it's not e
it's F oh this goes back here
oh oh then I probably could have opened
the doors over there I just didn't know
it
oh The Pink Door okay all right The Pink
Door een Mo I say get me in
there
F uh
oh what are you well this is lovely
I love the Aesthetics
coffee that's good sustenance is there
sustenance in the back rooms can I pull
this fire
alarm o
creepy creepy may I please I'm so
thirsty I am so oh God good
Lord that's dark and terrifying oh
oh that this is yeah uh-huh whoa oh boy
oh oh oh
spooky
um
uhhuh I just don't know where I'm going
now oh and we're going
down
help help
me I'm lost
I'm lost and
alone I ain't going near that chair that
chair is bad news anybody could know
that that chair when you've been playing
horror games as long as I have you know
that chair is bad news you don't want
nothing to do with that chair that chair
is not going to do you any good hey this
looks
familiar in the same way that everything
in here looks Vaguely
Familiar that's kind of the whole thing
of Lial spaces is that I feel Vaguely
Familiar
uh-huh is that an
elevator did I find an elevator am I
going to get out of
here all right farewell good for me I
did it thanks what is
this
and more back
rooms
yippee so I don't know if the concept of
like up and down actually mean anything
in the back rooms but I think I went
up
oh what am I what what am I looking
at a
wash
okay yeah
okay oh God don't do
that
okay hello you are out of place
here
uhhuh oh boy this place just is kind of
big huh
um so at what point do I lose hope and
start to eat my own eyes is that going
to happen soon or do I need
to
oh
okay
uh-huh
men all right what about
woman
uh-huh
uh-huh no
turlet I hate bathroom in horror games
if this could even be called a horror
game I'm not 100%
sure no that's going back I can tell
that's going back well um I don't know
where the freak I am and I don't know
what the freak I'm doing here and I
don't know if I'm supposed to
be dodging something running away from
something trying to get back home am I
thinking of my family do I have a
family oh man am I giving into despair
am I having an existential crisis
there's chairs over there that's
horrifying oh
vase oh
freak okay that that looks familiar okay
I think I think the way over here that I
didn't go even though I thought of it
right at the time I think the way that I
didn't go was actually the way that I
was supposed to go don't tell me how I
know or don't ask me how I know don't
tell me how I know definitely but don't
ask me how I know I've got
wow that's kind of
weird I do appreciate the bizarre
geometry I don't want anyone to think
that I just kind of hate on back rooms
for any particular reason because I'm
not I'm not hating on it I would I would
say these things about any
game but I have been walking around for
about almost 30 minutes here and so far
so
nothing chairs again different chairs
different room different slant what am I
seeing what are
you oh a
sign
oh thank you for shopping with us Merry
Christmas please return your baskets
here oh well don't mind if I do I
think yeah I'll I'll yeah why not can I
oh can I not crawl in that yeah I
can yeah I can go down lower lower
you've been lower than this before what
are you
doing there we go God
I don't know why but for some reason it
just didn't want to go down I'm going in
this hole you can't stop me because it's
the only thing that I've seen and there
was a sign up there and I haven't seen a
sign so I'm going to go in
here
hello
radio radio I heard a
radio
anybody
peekabo peekabo
peo help me what does it look like in
the dark it's freaking
dark oh God stop doing that stop why is
it
so sometimes the the mouse moves like
infinitesimally slow like there and then
other times it work moves like a million
miles hour
why oh it's got Mouse acceleration who
does that who does Mouse acceleration if
you have a trackpad I get that but Mouse
acceleration is a plague Mouse
acceleration is for babies babies that
can't do one to one well not one to one
but you know what I
mean okay I'm dropping
here uh yep apparently I am uh-huh well
I don't have to no clip to go here at
least and there I
go where am I what is this
place I know it's the back I know I know
I know what am I doing here why have I
been
cursed help me help me I think this is
the general mindset that you have when
you're in the back rooms I'm just trying
to fast forward through all the the
ideals why are you tipped over why are
you tipped over oh boy Escalades are
they moving no they're not of course
they're
not we all take him slow you got to be
careful you can't go too quickly if you
run you could die that's a scarest
danger of all oh God you might trip and
fall wouldn't want to break your nose in
the
bathrooms oh
God
interesting hey now we're getting
somewhere but what's
this oh God it's so terrifying I thought
it was natural sunlight I was almost
scared is that probably another way to
drop down maybe there's multiple paths
that's pretty
cool we hey is that working cool
train
BL
bedle bedle a fully functioning
train wow
oh
cool well this is cool
all
right
[Music]
uhhuh so who maintains all this mass
transit cuz I have some
questions okay thank
you oh
boy all
right oh
sound and sound's over I
guess you know if you were just to
scavenge things and plug them in
apparently there's power here so
apparently people can you know I take
that coffee machine take that laundry
machine I'm good to
go you know what I
[Music]
mean oh weird okay so we again flying
backwards but okay we got something here
we got something a little bit different
anyway not sure what or why but it's
different
okay well that was fun
man that was a good one that was great
that was
fantastic
ooh oh see I could live a good life here
not one but two stoves two I could be a
man balls wait a minute that doesn't
seem
good oh
okay wait a
minute
right
oh hi what are you doing there what are
you doing what do you think you're doing
here huh big guy you think you're so
tall huh you think just cuz I'm that
dick height doesn't mean that you're
you're better than
me that's what I
thought oh my
god oh stop that stop it all right I'm
out of here I'm out of here I'm I'm out
I'm out can that
stop why does that keep
happening it really needs to
cease
okay all
right
okay
mhm oh that's a nice
couch this is a dead end isn't
it
yep why does my vision keep getting
pulled in r random directions all right
I'm going back you better not be
there yeah yeah that's what I thought
you're not there are you you're not in
those windows right there are you
okay hey what are you
doing what are you doing hm you think
you're cool
H you think you're so funny
huh oh oh not there anymore huh too
afraid of the
repercussions he's a afraid of the
reaper
cushies the reaper cussies if you know
what I
mean hey look at that all right
easy well that wasn't any problem at all
I thought I was going to have to worry
about some or other over there that tall
guy ain't got nothing on slend man or
whatever he supposed to
be let me guess oh this is not what I
was going to
guess well that's practically
nice I like
stairs uhhuh I don't like this many
stairs
uh okay
I think we're at the Overlook
Hotel which I believe is the name of The
Shining
hotel bleep okay am I not going to
comment on that because it sure seems
like I should there's a lot of
doors
uhhuh uh-huh oh freck this
actually that's kind of
nice
weird bleep okay I feel like that's me
getting closer to
something can I not use my radio oh this
is circling back I don't know about this
unless it
isn't entrance North
too pristine it sure
is
exit this
ale
wonderful oh is that what did I find it
already damn I'm good get me out of
here damn I'm good if this is like the
way to progress which I don't really
100% know if it is I don't know if
that's what I exactly what I'm doing
here but I think I did
that man I hit the right
route oh no not the swimming
pool oh oh
this just reminded me there was that
other like randomly generated like SCP
back rooms kind of game with a monster
in it that I always said I was going to
go back and play some more
of and I never
did there's a lot of games like that
that i' I've gotten busy this year in
particular just with the movie has
been quite uh an Excursion in in hard
work can I drink this the only reason I
say that is because it looks so cool and
refreshing oh well there goes my running
oh it's goddamn Serene in here looks
beautiful I'm blind I can't see
[__]
well this definitely seems like a place
where nothing bad could happen
so certainly nothing will bad happen
nothing bad that's worse God turning my
light on made everything absolutely
worse
um it's
better this is awful I I hate this more
than I hate like the standard back rooms
layout the pool one I think lives in my
memory more just because it really
resonates with me in particular it's not
like I went to a lot of pools as a kid
but it just has that aesthetic that I
don't know the tiles and the weird
shallow water I it just like it rubs me
wrong oh this is better I like
this oh good more water
oh good I love the
sounds yeah this is
good oh this what stop doing that stop
it with the freaking Mouse acceleration
just doesn't make any
sense just every once in a while I just
go
what
is terrible for the
carpet let's
play
right pool
closing
why oh
good I don't think I want to go in
that indoor outdoor pools closing of
course they are
is this a church is that what this is
supposed to be is
church
uhhuh
uh this is cool I got to admit this is
cool I do like this this is pretty cool
I'm down to clown with this again that
happens I don't know why but whatever
it's pretty cool I like the pool
aesthetic I just wish that there was
some sense of tangibility into what I'm
doing right just walking through that's
a a staple of horror games right I don't
I ain't got nothing against like just
walking and exploring but I'm just very
curious of like if there's a way to like
Implement something that could make it
more of a game and like more of an
interactive experience than just like
forever lost in hallways of nothingness
right that's that's what I want is like
that extra
what
[Music]
uhhuh pretty
cool Ghost Train
oh do I have to
choose I choose this one it's like that
SCP where you got to choose the right
path or you're
doomed am I doomed am I
dead am I
doomed oh no I'm
fine I don't even know if you can die in
the back
rooms
and we're back
baby here in some weirdness but we're
back almost like we never
left okay these are the extra
lost back rooms I can't find anything
here oh there we go never never
mind found
something
uhhuh
uhuh well there we
go appreciate the elevators the
elevators are super dope if they could
just get me back to wherever I need to
go the surface the
bottom whatever it is I'm
down how many of these are going to be
how many of these are there going to be
I know that's the point of the back
rooms is you're lost forever in an
eternity I get that I get that I
stop doing that to my
mouse it's fine ooh this looks different
and I
know I know I've played many any games
like this where you go endlessly through
rooms before I've done that I know and I
can't I'm not
complaining now what I'm doing is not
complaining I would never complain cuz
remember Spooky's House of jump scares
or Spooky's jump scare Mansion whatever
they had to rename it to it's
Church oh
boy anyway that you had to go through
like thousand rooms thous thousand plus
I'm turning my light on and off I I
forget the f is the use button
here but I'm just wondering how much
longer I'm going to be doing this there
was one spooky thing that I'm going to
sit in the timeout
chair okay good great cuz there was one
spooky thing that happened and that was
really cool and I like that and I'm like
you could put a few more I'm just saying
you could put like two
more I'm just so ready for it you know
I've been to church before I remember I
what that's like and there's nothing
else here but it's fine it's fine this
is this is the experience this is part
of the experience I'm glad I almost
missed that I almost missed church that
was really something church I'm not
[__] on the game that's not what I'm
doing it's not what I'm doing it's not
what I'm doing I think it's part of the
experience to be aggravated that I can't
get out of here and I know that's the
whole deal that that is the whole deal
the whole deal is this I get that I'm
with it I'm I'm syned up I'm in the
experience I'm vibing with it says
there's an exit here I wonder if it's
true that was my light not the button I
get it I get it you know I get it I do I
do I get it I I get it hey look at this
he got a
shoe oh oh yeah now we're getting here
it's the
mall it's the Tri County
mall wow I love them all I love them
[Music]
all I don't know what it is I love a
mall I love being in a mall I love
walking around a mall I don't have a
mall near me I wish cuz I mean malls are
kind of dying but I don't think they'll
ever fully die because I mean like I I
buy everything online these days but I
love a mall God I love a mall man I just
wish I could walk around a
mall love them all I could just end it
right here I could end it right here you
know what I'd be fine with
this your ad here make your brand
visible to hundreds of people daily I'm
sure like look at this this is what it
means to live this is what people
crave I don't know this is not what
people crave but this is what I crave
man I love a mall I need more Mall
horror games that's what I
need oh you thought you could get away
from me huh oh I found you you thought
you was going to hide oh there's nothing
here just ice cream can I get some
scream got any cream no damn thought
there might have been some cream
media
[Music]
play well that's the that that might be
the creepiest thing I've seen in this
game yet oh that's unsettling so I'd be
fine if it's like more of this I love
this I love you know I love seeing weird
locations I love the concept I love the
concept of it like I want to play a game
that is like there's an SCP about it but
this is the thing about the backrounds
like I feel like it's one slice of
something and it's not enough meat there
to tie everything together because this
is dope these more limal spaces like
this this is what I'm all about but it's
got to actually be a Lial space you know
there's only so much you can get out of
just like wallpaper walls and the terror
of going I'm lost you know I [__]
love this [__] I love this [__] I get
this I'm all about this I'm 100% about
this cuz I love a mall that's the thing
I love a mall I love a big store I love
smelling all the I love smelling all the
crap in there I love it all I love it
all I love this
aesthetic it's not even a Nostalgia
thing I just love the aesthetic I love
the now of it cuz this is the now of it
cuz all these stores are closing that's
the now of it it's not
Nostalgia this is how it is that's what
I love yeah this is what I want give me
more malls but I don't get the back
rooms or I'm admitting I'm admitting it
I don't get it I I don't get I'm not
about it doesn't it doesn't make sense
for me it doesn't make sense there's a
great SCP about like this freaking Ikea
that goes on forever that's M deal
that's that's monotonous and boring and
you know that's kind of like the Ikea
experien is you going up Loop and you
you could get lost for forever right
near me well not near me but nearish to
me is one of the biggest Ikeas in the
world
[Music]
oh what's that about love that love that
love that love them all love them all
God love them all love them all look
this this is different this is different
ah see now this is a back room this is
yeah that's what I'm talking about yeah
this is getting good now it's getting
good it wasn't good before I'm going to
readily admit it it wasn't good not good
for me it was a little good here and
there but it wasn't doing it for me oh
yeah let me down here yeah give me
something yeah scare me that's what I
want yeah give me the yeah play some
weird noises yeah do it yeah do that
thing yeah oh is it a dead end do I got
to turn around is there something behind
me oh no I thought there was yeah
[Music]
no I deserve better than this I deserve
better than this I deserve better than
this I deserve better than this I
deserve better than the back rooms I
deserve better than this I deserve
better than this you know I was having
such a good time in that mall I was oh I
was in the swimming pool I was having a
great time splashing around doing all
sorts of Mark BL things that you don't
need to worry about well that's kind of
cool scar me scare me give me a garden
of band band Big clay face coming out of
the ground give me that [__] give me
that [__] give me that [__] give me the
breathing yes yes no no a it's a Subway
again
ohway
I'm fine I'm fine I'm enjoying myself I
would never
not I'm having a great time and you know
this is the point of this for me to
spiral into madness because that's what
happens when you're lost in the back
rooms that's what I'm I'm having a trer
experience than you could ever even
possibly have you know what that's the
truth that's the truth of it that's the
truth of the back room right I I
understand where you
don't [__] I I think you don't even
know who I
am if you made it this far in the video
then you certainly don't you certainly
are starting to but you don't know you
don't know
Green I love
green and Green's over okay good I was
wondering when that was going to be over
I hate green hate it with a
passion
man it's a good thing they put a run
button in but my pinky is about to fall
off can I get another mole scare me
scare me do it scare me give me
something good yeah give me that yeah
give me something yeah keep going into
the loops yeah no I want to be in the
loops of the darkness give me more
Loop yeah give me the loops no let me
look up in the oh man I thought there
was going to be something
there it's fine I'll go this other way
to the the other re over here yeah give
me this [__] you know I'm starting you
know I I was thinking for a second there
that I played this game before but then
I realized that these games all kind of
look the same cuz the back rooms all
kind of look the same so it's all one
big game experience it Blends into
another there's really no separation
between one game and the other so even
though it says it's not connected to
[Music]
Green I I don't mind
green now I hate
green would you look at that
well would you look at
that I pretty good I'm pretty good right
there I'm pretty
good is that hole in the floor oh it's a
cut
scene sh would be a shame as well to
shove shove me shove me in there shove
me shove me in
there
shove me I
fell
oh hello and B I'm in the Frozen flu
section
so I kind of lost it there but I'm good
I'm back kind of snap me out of the
nonsense of it all hey wait a minute hey
wait a minute
whoa
oh oh don't mind if I do I'm getting out
of
here Freedom there better not be there
better be something behind me oh yeah
there's something behind me isn't there
oh yeah no damn it
ah
interesting oh am I
free am I free no
way oh no
way ohoh hey
is anyone in
here
G something tells me I might not be free
no damn it I keep doing
that locked I've never seen a locked
door
before
hey you
guys
oh
uh-huh
uhoh oh no no no no no
[Music]
no
oh oh
[__]
[Music]
for
all right I did it and I want to say I
don't dislike it or I yeah I don't
dislike it it's not that I don't like it
that's a thing whenever I complain about
these kind of things it's not because I
hate what's happening here this was
obviously made well and it it well I
mean it was made it was made completely
and seemed well it's hard to tell with
these things and that's fine but here's
the thing the one thing that I wish all
of these had is that it would maintain
the sense that there's danger lurking
around the corners that's what I feel
makes it and it's okay okay to like
create areas where there's complacency
and you feel accustomed to something
because that's good that's what happens
in a lot of horror games but it's it's
kind of like an opportunity to turn that
boredom on its head and then kind of
take the player by surprise and it did
it a few times that's that's what's good
love them all that's not what did it but
I I love them all love them all anyway I
just can't help but walk away from these
feeling like that is a little bit crazy
God can you imagine if I wasn't
sprinting through that the whole time
can you imagine cuz I can't I can't
imagine that anyway I did enjoy
myself to some degree and I'm not going
to say anything critical about it that's
all I'm going to leave it to that I I'm
leaving it that thank you everybody so
much for
watching I love
you I love
you thank you and as always I will see
you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye